on the last jackass movie yeah knoxville  stood in front of a bull got scooped and  sent into a one and a half rotation flip  where he landed on his head yeah got a  brain hemorrhage  broken rib broken wrist you guys worried  about like ct and [ __ ] um do you think  that's what happened to bam  i don't know i'm not a doctor but uh  actually  i don't know with the bam situation but  i'm [ __ ] worried about knoxville's  brain i've i i i have been like if you  saw the first jackass movie when he got  knocked out by butter beans the way that  he was snoring when you get knocked out  and you're like snoring loudly like  that's not good for your brain yeah  knoxville's had way too many of those  yeah